Đây là có hỏi vì đổ dịch trình và gọi đường rất sẽ làm sai
Sẵn bài trọng tâm giữa kiêm một phẩm biết cái chiêm bài tử lạc sau đây
Cái bây giờ mình nghĩ mấy, bây giờ mình nghĩ mấy
Bây giờ mình nghĩ là vì chi nhà của em, bây giờ mình chỉ bư đi
Mong, tìm tà hóa, nó mà chung điểm xe
Cái bây giờ mình nghĩu trọng nhà em là mốt cơ đúng
Đấy cái bây giờ nhé
Đấy cái bây giờ, xe là một điểm mà là chung điểm, bây giờ nhé
Nó là nhà em, mong nhạc
Mấy là mình chỉ có bí bệ
Vì xe là tìm tạm và đúng được
Tạm và đúng được
Tạm và đúng sẽ làm chúng mình xe nhé
Này là biết mùi, mình là là này
Nó là đúng là, mình là cán ngồi đúng rồi
Sánh quang đúng rồi, mình chuyện
Mày trọng xả làm mình thích là hay quý xe rộn
Mày trọng đó là mình phải xảy quý xe rộn
Đúng rồi, mình có những những người ta trọng quá
Đi biết quý xe của thì bây giờ mình sẽ quý xe của đi bà đồ
Nếu trọng nhà em là mốt cơ đúng
Đúng rồi
Tuo là gì vậy?
Tôi là gốc tôi là không ngủ thích thích thích thích thích thích thích nhé
Đại thì bạn tạc này
Đúng không
Chỉu dương là gốc tưởng tu nhé để biểu kìa
Đại chỉ dương quay đúng vậy
Đúng không
Đại
Chỉu dương quay đúng
Được trên nào
Đại khi anh kết trở lại là thích chút được quá
Nhà, thì mình là nhà
Còn, thì sao mình thì thấy
Các cái tạc lụ
Rồi để bà nhé
Sẵn như thế là đủ
Thế cả
Đúng rồi, đủ để bà đầy nằm đau
Tổ lý mây là bà ngon nhau
Bây giờ sẽ ngon nhau
1, 2, 3, 4, 4,